let's go to athens georgia where derek
joins us derek how can we help
hey how are you doing we are living the
dream what's going on
here i got a quick question it's kind of
for my wife um
she's about she's no debt she's got
about two 220
k saved up she's 38 she'll be retiring
in two years we're having our first baby
uh so at 40 you know she won't be
working she'll be spending
all day full-time on kind of deal by
that time she'll have 450 500 saved up
like i said we have no debt so my
question is
i'm starting to get a little older and
i'm wondering with her money and her
income and everything
she'll have saved up at that point um
what ideas do you have to where where to
put that money
safely you know in case something
happens to me
first of all i don't i don't really
believe in the stock market and
all that stuff um just kind of what
other ideas you got out of the box as
far as that goes
you know chris before you dive into that
i i he's saying something very
interesting i've picked up on it derek i
just need a little bit more
uh light shed on the situation you keep
calling it her money
her money if it's money well what do you
mean
where's the hour money part i'm a little
confused why you're calling it her money
well we have separate we we don't miss
our monies
why well i mean to be blatantly honest
when we met
um i had a lot more than her and i still
do and i don't want her to feel like
that she
that's she's dependent on that i told
her you know you i'll help you make
yours
and what yours is yours um obviously you
know i paid for everything
[Laughter]
i just didn't uh i wasn't going to have
that you know
so derek how long have you all been
married
uh we've been together almost six years
been there at about two
okay and you all have kids
no the first baby's on the way first
baby okay
first baby's on the way all right so
well in two years
yeah okay all right well he here's the
deal
uh go ahead coleman i feel you twitching
over here
no no no no man i'm not listening we're
not i'm not gonna beat up on you but
but but we believe that that it's your
money
that both of you as a unified couple
should have a unified
bank account and i'm not i'm not here to
attack
you know your reasoning behind that uh
but you know i never want her to feel
like she was dependent on me well i
think you've made your point
i think she's done a good job but i
think it's time for we
i mean chris you're the one that always
says we need to speak speak prince
french
speak french derek i've never been to
france but i know how to speak it and
it's we
speak don't don't say me speak we and
here's why i say this
uh you obviously care about this lady um
she's getting ready to be the mother of
your kids
and that mindset of you working hard and
your
work ethic and your diligence you want
to kind of pull that together and have
that full-on
mental process of you guys working
together as a team
and i can tell by the sound of your
voice you grew up playing sports didn't
you
yeah what was your favorite sport
uh football not a big golfer but
football was mine when i was able to
what side of the ball do you play
offense or defense
i like defense what's up much simpler
you just tackle the man with the ball
yeah i hear your brother
we're cut from the same cloth he likes
running to score i love hitting people
yeah but here's the thing i want you to
tackle this life stuff together with her
and i think working together on your
finances and
you know it sounds like you may have
been burned at some point in time or
or had something happen financially and
working together as a team you're going
to get to where you want to go a lot
faster now real quick i want to shift on
that
and you guys may need to do some
marriage counseling on this you know
before you have a kid so you can find
out what is that thing that's blocking
you
and marriage counseling is not a bad
thing or therapy is not a negative it's
a help it's a fine tuner
but you said something else i want to
hit on you said you don't believe in the
stock market
yeah why well i'm
just real quick when i retired i talked
to my stock market buddy and he said why
don't you go in there and ask the guy
what he's worth and you tell them what's
your word and what sense does it make to
give a guy
worth a hundred thousand dollars a
million dollars no i agree
i agree and so it's not about the market
that's about an individual
so what is and i understand that but i'm
a physical asset guy
like me i know if i put 400 000 in the
property that property is there that
property value is going to go up
nothing's going to happen to it but i
don't know if i give like anybody money
where it's going to be by 9 o'clock
tonight it may be in japan and
at the bottom line i don't trust other
people with my money okay now that's
where we're heading
on and that's a real that's a real thing
that's real and i will also i've got to
ask you derek
do you i mean this do you trust your
wife
i'm a hundred percent okay listen i
understand the question
all right listen to me but because i
think you're a guy who doesn't give
trust
easily and i don't think that's a
negative my man you're a man of
friendship
to get it yes sir i get it but listen to
me brother
the amount of money that she's got the
amount of the money that you guys got
if you put it together yeah and you do
it chris chris take over these mutual
funds and
your smart investing my man listen to me
you got to loosen up a little bit you're
going to thank us for it
well and the reason i'm asking you about
that is i think you know it is a matter
of working with an individual that's
going to help you grow that money
uh you can be a physical asset guy you
can but you and i both know
a physical asset is only worth what
somebody's willing to pay for it
right you can have a property and you
can say hey i'm going to list this thing
for sale at 450.
if it's in a terrible area or it's a bad
property it's not going to sell
so you in the mindset of diversification
i like the mindset of you obviously if
you're going to buy real estate
my thought is you only want to do it
with cash uh first and foremost
uh you you i don't want you taking on
mortgages and all that other stuff
you're gonna invest you do it with cash
the other side of it is diversify
yourself derek
listen put some of that money in some
growth stock mutual funds
i'm not talking about buying bitcoin and
and and
crypto grump tree you're all that old
crazy stuff no put it in gross stock
mutual funds this way this money is
going to work for you
i know you work hard to make this money
make your money work do me a favor
get in connection with the smartmaster
pro have a conversation
lay out your dreams and goals and let's
see what they can do for you interview
them
how much are they managing don't look at
their personal salary
what have they done make them show you
the scoreboard you're a scoreboard guy i
like that
but man you got to learn to trust but do
homework trust and verify